season eight of NCIS Los Angeles  premieres this Sunday and for the stars  of the show it's like a family reunion  cast especially can a lot of times feel  like your siblings  you know in their days where you love  each other and you hate each other even  if they feel like brothers Chris won't  mess with his co-star LL Cool J aka Todd  Smith that is one of the strongest dude  you will ever run into as we all know  Todd is a is a force to be reckoned with  ah yeah I'm in the game  ll is also busy hosting lip sync battle  and he'd love to see his fellow special  agents on stage I hope to uh you know  get some of the guys on this show over  there at some point that would be a lot  of fun but would they perform any of ll  's old-school songs I've always asked  him for one of his gold chains I said I  know you've got a bunch of them at home  and this step one  you